Today’s 1 Minute Monday is
support someone!
Find someone in your network
who you can help today.
So here’s a quick story;
I work with an agent
and this guy represents
a whole bunch of thought leaders
and a lot of them are trying to make videos.
And he brought in a new client
and I checked out on of her videos
and she’s just getting started but I liked video
and so I gave it a thumbs-up on YouTube
and left a comment on it saying that I liked it.
And I did that because I remember
when I was first getting started
and nobody left any comments
and I was barely getting any views.
And I felt like I was pouring my heat into something
and nobody cared about it.
And she’s in that same spot now where
you know, not getting
a lot on comments on the videos
not getting a lot of views
and I remember when I got a comment
I felt so good like
“Yes! Somebody cares!”
And so today I got to be that somebody for her
and give her a little bit more energy
and motivation and a boost.
So support the people in your network.
It’ll make you feel good
it’ll make them feel good
and it will help your business as well.
Believe.